herr die krawall nächten und stuttgart
und frankfurt bei denen in den
innenstädten randaliert wurde und
mehrere polizisten verletzt wurden
sie waren einschneidend und zwar für
ganz deutschland
hier sehen wir noch mal die bilder aus
stuttgart mit welcher brutalität die
randalierer polizisten angriffen
jetzt schlagen drei oberbürgermeister
aus drei verschiedenen parteien in einem
brandbrief alarm man müsse ehrlich und
offen nach den ursachen fragen heißt es
in dem brief den richard arnold
oberbürgermeister von schwäbisch gmünd
matthias klopfer ub aus schondorf und
boris palmer von den grünen aus tübingen
fordern in jeder mittelstadt in baden
württemberg hat sich mittlerweile ein
milieu nicht integrierter häufig mit
kleinkriminalität und straftaten in
verbindung zu bringen da junger
geflüchteter männer gebildet das an
bahnhöfen und öffentlichen plätzen
zusammen kommt heißt es in dem brief an
baden württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann
von diesen seien mittlerweile viele
nicht mehr für sozial oder
integrationsangebote erreichbar die
forderung der politiker ein
pflichtdienst an der gesellschaft auch
um mangelnder integration
entgegenzutreten
mir sind diese drei oberbürgermeister
jetzt zugeschaltet ich begrüße ganz
herzlich sich ein arnold von der cdu
oberbürgermeister aus schwer bestritt
matthias klopfer spd-oberbürgermeister
in schorndorf und boris palmer von den
grünen op in tübingen ganz herzlich
willkommen
sie sind in unterschiedlichen parteien
zu hause sie einiges aber eine forderung
und zwar offen und ehrlich mit den
ursachen der krawalle umzugehen da was
sind die ursachen herr arnold vielleicht
wollen sie beginnen
vielen dank die ursachen liegen darin
wir können eine kleine gruppe der
geflüchteten nicht erreichen es ist
richtig die webseite geflüchteten wir in
schwäbisch gmünd die haben wir in eine
ausbildung bringen können die sind auch
sehr willig zu sich zu integrieren aber
da gibt es noch eine kleine gruppe da
klappt das nicht und da brauchen wir
einfach andere maßnahmen da brauchen wir
einfach ein anderes vorgehen da wird der
staat empfunden als zu schwach das kommt
auch daher dass wenn die straffällig
werde
dass sie dann nicht sofort bestraft
werden sondern das dauert dann viel zu
lange als wir brauchen da auch viel
einfiel selbstbewussteres mutiges
auftreten des rechtsstaates der viel
schneller handelt herr klopfer haben
auch sie das gefühl es wurde bisher
nicht offen genug über die ursachen
gesprochen und woran liegt das
wir hatten natürlich eine politische
emotional aufgeladene debatte in
deutschland
die wir kommen apotheker vor ort waren
die eigentlichen integrationsmanagement
im jahr 2015 2016 haben vieles richtig
gemacht
allein in unserer stadt mit 40.000
einwohnern ein paar tausend flüchtlinge
da habe ich sehr gut integriert aber wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass sind
derzeit ist uns nicht gelungen ist
einige bildeten nicht zu integrieren
dieses hätten wir vielleicht in der
kollege palma früher thematisieren
müssen dass manche auch nicht
integrationswillig sind
die fakten müssen formuliert werden und
man sich das aber in stuttgart bei den
50 die jetzt aktuell polizeilich
ermittelt werbung haben die acht würde
ich auch deutsche eltern von daher
müssen wir in der region stuttgart oder
geprägt sind viele menschen mit
internationalen schauen was ist er
integrationswillig ist ja das eine aber
welche integrationsangebote gibt es denn
herr palmer integrationsangebote gibt es
viele in schwäbischen schorndorf oder
tübingen und die die sie wahrnehmen die
machen auch einen erfolgreichen weg in
unserer gesellschaft gerade habe ich mir
eine statistik zeigen lassen wie viel so
viel verdienen dass sie nicht mehr auf
öffentliche unterstützung angewiesen
sind sondern selbst ihre wohnung
bezahlen können das entwickelt sich gut
was uns fehlt sind geeignete sanktionen
für die die nicht wollen und es wäre
sehr erstaunlich wenn unter der
millionen menschen die zu uns gekommen
sind niemand dabei wäre der unwillig ist
der sich nicht zur leistung von selbst
aufraffen kann und er sagt ja wenn ich
nicht muss dann lasse ich es bleiben
schließlich gibt es ja auch in unserer
gesellschaft solche menschen und hier
brauchen wir ein geeignetes
sanktionsinstrument es reicht nicht nur
angebote zu machen das ist die
vorstellung von sozialromantik kommt
wenn es so wäre dass angebote allein
ausreichen würden
würden wir gar keine polizei benötigen
aber wir brauchen sie ja wohl doch heran
alt in schwäbisch gmünd wurden
asylbewerber eingesetzt als kofferträger
für einen euro am bahnhof halten sie das
für ein gutes integrations konzept also
zumindest sage ich ihnen die menschen
die damit gemacht haben die fühlten sich
gebraucht und sie waren stolz drauf dass
sie sich einbringen konnten und dass sie
zeigen konnten was sie drauf haben
welche fähigkeiten dass wir haben aber
sehen sie heute morgen habe ich einen
getroffen hat gestern seine
gesellenprüfung abgelegt als schreiner
der junge der ist bis heute nicht in das
bis heute hat er keinen aufenthalt also
wenn jemand sich ordentlich aufhört und
auch formal keine bleibeperspektive
haslach hat dann brauchen doch gerade
solche die sich anstrengen die was
leisten brauchen doch dann auch in al
rai zungen angebot dass sie hier bleiben
können die können wir doch dann brauchen
aber andere die straffällig werden so
wie es kollege palma schon immer
thematisiert hat die müssen sanktionen
fürchten und bisher klappt das nicht und
das muss man doch mal sagen dürfen diese
bilder die wir da gesehen haben vorher
von frankfurt das kann doch so nicht
weitergehen die bürger hier in gmünd in
schorndorf und in tübingen regen sich
auf ich will ja gar nicht ins
thematisieren was das alles kostet
herr palmer warum spielt er
migrationshintergrund die herkunft von
tätern überhaupt eine rolle wenn wir
über die krallen echte sprechen und was
denken sie muss bei der integration
passieren also erstmals spielt an der
rolle weil die zahlen des zeigen
geflüchtete machen etwa zwei prozent der
bevölkerung in deutschland aus sie sind
aber etwa 10 bis 15 prozent je nach
straftat bei den schweren
sexualstraftaten und gewaltdelikten nach
der polizeilichen kriminalstatistik also
deutlich überrepräsentiert
und deshalb sehen wir eben auch in
frankfurt und in stuttgart das war schon
auf den videos zu erkennen aber
mittlerweile hat die polizei das auch
nachermittelt und meer geflüchtet
unter den verhafteten stuttgart als
menschen ohne migrationshintergrund
das muss jetzt hellhörig machen also die
zahlen auch fordern dass wir hier
differenzieren und wenn sie jetzt fragen
was wohl die ursache ist das eine ist
erstmal die empirische beobachtung was
wohl die ursache ist habe ich eine
einfache these wir alle sind uns
ziemlich einig dass länder wie saudi
arabien furchtbarer gesellschaftliche
verhältnisse haben das patriarchat
regiert trauen werden unterdrückt
schwule werden mit dem strafrecht
verfolgt ist in gesellschaften die
unseren modernisierungs und
investitionsprozess noch nicht
durchlaufen haben menschen die dort
aufwachsen und sozialisiert werden haben
bisher alles im gepäck wenn sie zu uns
kommen viele lassen sich dann bei uns
auf die neuen verhältnisse ein und
können sich integrieren aber schon
manche ist die aufgabe zu schwer
und wenn sie da nicht fordern wenn man
sie nicht auch bei fehlverhalten klar
mit einer gelben oder roten karte darauf
hinweist dass das bei uns eben nicht
geht so wie es bei ihnen war mit gewalt
und männlichkeit ritualen
dann werden sie sich nicht ändern diese
sozialisation die gibt es wenn wir sie
in den herkunftsländern kritisieren dann
müssen wir auch lernen damit umzugehen
wenn menschen aus diesen ländern zu uns
kommen und einfach nur mit angeboten
noch mal das wird nicht reichen
herr klapper sehen sie das auch so es
geht um integration aber auch um
sozialisation wie kann man es erreichen
und gleichzeitig muss der staat aber
klarmachen dass er das gewaltmonopol
hatten haben sicherlich auch zu billig
polizei ermittelte schon darauf mit über
100000 einwohner streifen unterwegs ist
ja nicht mal in der lage das thema
häusliche gewalt der wahl bahnhofs
kriminalität drogenhandel und vieles
mehr überhaupt noch zu kontrollieren
habe sich auch unverzichtbar und
gleichzeitig müssen wir unsere
integrationsbemühungen ansteigenden vor
allem diejenigen die wirklich hier
beiden ständig r lebensunterhalt
verdienen wollen aber sagen aber der sei
herzlich willkommen da machen wir große
fehler der woche bekomme ich einen brief
einem handwerksmeister mittelständische
unternehmer immer sagen jetzt ist dass
mitarbeiter aus gambia afghanistan 23
jahren beschäftigt und fahrrad geschoben
das macht ja gar keine zehn versuchen
händeringend mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter schickt man die in der
arbeitslosigkeit die sind frustriert
weil sie keine zukunftsperspektive haben
dazu kommt der brandbeschleuniger und
ich habe schon öfters wir uns konsequent
dem thema alkohol als viel zu weiche
droge im umgang in der gesellschaft
anzubieten zeugen
das haben wir viel über integration
gesprochen in ihrem schreiben benutzen
sie die ausdrücke krawallbrüder und
trotz boomender habe sind das
bezeichnungen die man ihnen diesen
zusammenhang verwenden sollte die
passend sind herr palmer ich habe dafür
auf facebook viel kritik geerntet weil
es viel zu harmlos heißt so meinen die
einen
es würde ja die gewalt die wir gesehen
haben wir in dieser polizisten massiv
angegriffen wird in hätte auch die
wirbelsäule brechen können würde das
völlig harmlosen und andere meinen das
sei eine diskriminierung der
angesprochenen gruppe ich sage es mal so
unter uns drei schwäbischen
oberbürgermeister und drückt es so aus
und der ja dazu sind sie bloß dafür darf
sich andere begriffe suchen
das problem dieser debatte ist aber dass
man viel zu sehr über die nebensachen
redet über begrifflichkeiten entsetzlich
aber mal hart den tatsachen zuzuwenden
und unser vorschlag sagt ja im kern die
leute die da randaliert haben
die leben in einem falschen anreiz
system wenn sie sich anstrengen dann
wird es nicht belohnt dann werden sie
wahrscheinlich trotzdem abgeschoben und
wenn sie sich fehlverhalten dann wird es
nicht sanktioniert das heißt die
verstehen das als einladung das man so
weitermachen kann bei uns in der
gesellschaft ist auch für diese person
schlecht dass ihr viele geflüchtete
dabei die geraten auf die schiefe bahn
weil wir nicht einschreiten das wollen
wir ändern uns kommunalpolitiker ist
halt wichtiger dass es funktioniert als
ob es zum parteiprogramm passt deswegen
sind wir auch überparteilich zusammen
wir sagen wir brauchen funktionierende
anreiz und sanktionssystem
um diese probleme im griff zu bekommen
bisher haben wir den nicht und da muss
die politik reagieren überparteilich
einig sind sie sich auch darin dass ein
pflichtdienst an der gesellschaft helfen
würde herr arnold für wen sei der gelten
und wie soll der genau aussehen also
nach unseren vorstellungen soll diese
pflichtdienst für alle gelten also nicht
nur für die die neu zu uns dazu gekommen
sind die sicherlich wie boris palmer und
der matthias klopfer das formuliert
haben hier auch vieles an regeln lernen
müssen die da sozialisiert müssen
sondern wir haben das müssen wir auch
einfach thematisieren bei uns sehr viele
dänen täte ist gut wenn sie ein solches
ja einmal einfach
nun nutzen könnten um sich auch
auszuprobieren und dazu rechne ich auch
diejenigen die zum beispiel in besseren
verhältnissen aufwachsen die mehr auf
der sonnenseite des lebens stehen wir
haben doch eine gesellschaft die geprägt
ist immer mehr von individualisierung
und von egoismen und da täte ist doch
gut wenn alles so ein dienst machen
müssen denn alle einer dienstpflicht
nachkommen müssen und wer mehr statt
weniger gemeinsamkeit hätten und wenn
wir so einen gemeinsamen erfahrungsraum
hätten über eine solche dienstpflicht im
übrigen im moment werden so viele
freiwilligen dienste angeboten
ich habe den eindruck damit drückt sich
berlin damit drücken sich die
landeshauptstädter um diese frage sollen
wir denn nicht eine allgemeine
dienstpflicht einführen
die drücken sich darum mit dem sie jeden
tag einen neuen dienst auffinden
herr klapper stimmen sie dem zu wahren
kann dass er nicht freiwillig ablaufen
was ich selber zu wenig gemacht begonnen
haben
dezember 1980 den ersten tag kapitals
zwangsdienst empfunden und danach waren
das die 20-erfolg monate meines lebens
habe unglaublich viel gelernt im umgang
mit menschen mit behinderung und damit
würde schwer sprechen dort auch das sind
prägende erfahrungen die einen
willkommenen test positiv begleiten der
gesellschaft auch etwas zurückzugeben
leute macht man das abitur mit 18
dafür hat alles angesprochen dass gerade
auf der sonnenseite des lebens stehen
mitzunehmen machen klassentreffen
mittlerweile nach dem abitur in
südamerika in neuseeland oder in einer
straße in die laube es könnten jahr
später machen nach ihrem bachelor
studium vor sich engagieren
im pflegedienst im umgang mit
demenzkranken älteren menschen auch für
die umwelt da es sich einzusetzen im
rettungsdienst es gibt einen ganz wenn
sie vielfältige aufgaben in unserer
gesellschaft wo mehr menschen brauchen
damit menschlichkeit und es wird für das
positive miteinander in unserer
gesellschaft einen großen sprung nach
vorne gehen herr peymann ihrer partei
sieht man dass er vielleicht durchaus
anlass das könnte doch auch freiwillig
ablaufen sie sind aber dennoch für eine
pflicht zur gleichen lebenserfahrung aus
die kollege klopp passt geschildert hat
auch mein zivildienst im rettungsdienst
hat zum einen lebenshilfe
juli
schulbank in die hörsaal bank gewechselt
das war wichtig für mich und ich glaube
dass das tatsächlich für alle jungen
menschen wichtig sein könnte und ich
denke dass es jetzt noch wichtiger ist
als es zu unserer zeit war weil wir in
einer gesellschaft leben die immer
weiter auseinander fällt die in gruppen
zerfällt ja als
einwanderungsgesellschaft überhaupt
erstmal gemeinsamkeit herstellen muss
und dafür sind gemeinsame soziale
aufgaben die man schichten unabhängig
verrichtet wo man miteinander in kontakt
kommt nach meiner festen überzeugung
genau richtig und es ist nicht liberal
sondern das ist gerade die voraussetzung
für gelebte die banalität wir sehen ja
was passiert wenn die gesellschaft
auseinanderfällt eine stadt wie
frankfurt plötzlich und polizei
monatelang in ausnahmezustand versetzt
deswegen sind auch liberale vordringen
aber ich schätze es fukuyama auf diese
seite gewechselt oder heribert prantl
weil sie sagen so wie unsere
gesellschaft mittlerweile geradezu
explodiert und die ränder zu ausfranst
wie sie über die sozialen medien die
eigentliche soziale medien sind immer
weiter in sich verfeindete gruppen
gegenübersteht ist es wichtig eine
gegenmaßnahme zurückgreifen und ein
sozialer pflichtdienst für alle wäre
genau diese passende gegenmaßnahme
interessant ist auch 77 prozent der
bevölkerung hinter dem stehen wenn man
umfragen glauben darf